haben noch ein sehr geiles auch das
alter ist teamwork servo sechs kids und
herzlich willkommen zu einer neuen folge
zuschauer überrascht so wie das immer
funktioniert bin ich schon auf meinem
team speed suchen wir jetzt gleich ein
channel raus in den ich einräume und
dann werde ich einfach mit fremden
idealerweise zuschauern von mir eine
oder zwei münchen minecraft spielen und
das ganze für mich aufnehmen
ich schaue jetzt gerade mal wen könnte
man hier auswählen vier personen drei
personen drei personen
ich gehe mal hier rein
habt ihr bock auf etwas chili
installiert ausmachen
ihre tiere team
woher um uns selbst und wir werden euch
nicht premium okay also leute wenn es
drei herren im team herr creepy ferrari
und der regel aber es sieht aus als
würde es gut werden uns ja ok
naja leute stellt euch doch mal kurz vor
der reihe nach was ich von oben nach
unten
übertreibt gerne mag mich gehört das
muss jetzt du bist der crazy drauf alte
meine letzte ohne pathos wie lange ist
die bitte her mettwurst ich hab keine
achtung dieses spiel hockey blog
das weiß ich damit kommen wir sollten
nicht die ersten sein so simon
tsr popcorn hour ingame heißt du etwas
über das verbrechen begangen
ja so viel wie viele 3 oder gold
alle verbrechen begangen ich komme ich
zurück schnell vom blog
jannis oder haben wir zu guter letzt
noch prinz oder ich bin 20 klar
disziplin
dann bin ich auch ganz ehrlich die ganze
zeit
also ich hab schon entdeckt ist knackig
ist alles klar okay dann komme ich
vielleicht kurz mal zur hälfte hielt
einfach nur der base aber in den basics
auch goldsponsor aufpassen
nicht so die krassesten raid aber okay
okay ich rasch mal auf gelb und gelb
ausgelöst ausgelöscht ausgelöst
ausgleich ausgelöst
gäste hatten zwar schon genug leider
okay ja krass 20 neue jumping modul das
ist heftig man ja das ist frick heftig
heftig sowie ein ding in die ich früher
meine vokabeln reingeschrieben habe will
ich alter blauer baut sich ganz schön
frech rüber zu uns nehmen zu grün oder
hallo hallo okay meinte die haben bogen
blau und grün eigentlich ja ich glaub ja
nicht blöd sich kann zu grün rüber aus
irgendein grund und schaut erst mal in
die mitte ich habe bogen ja denkt dass
man hier über gehen und die hier
bisschen attackieren
ja okay alles gut alles gut alles gut
das dauert noch eine weile
ich kenne es nix erkennen teilweise lag
die animation ja auch aber es sieht
nicht gut aus bis nach rechts bauen nach
hier also nach hinten bei dir genau
ja ja ist leichter als stehtische
gerettet wenn ich mal kurz um genau dort
sehr gut ok dann rein da oben siehst du
was
okay bin getroffen habe ja auch mal
getroffen habe
ok dann kommst du die mitte er kommt
darüber ja jetzt attacke so heftig mit
epics haben noch ein sehr ist auch da
altern ist teamwork okay ich kann aber
bekam war die brücke hier sehr gut ja
easy bisschen gold schwer zerstört
manchmal ist es okay okay ich boxe sie
einfach jetzt gerade mal schwer zugleich
dann okay dann egal dann nimmt heute in
schwedt kaputt so wie sieht's aus dem
bett um grün macht auch keine
geschichten die bauen sich einfach nur
krass 12
der kollege nicht lang das bett ich ganz
schön krass eingebaut kann das sein ich
hole mal kurz erklärt kurz auslöschen
ich unbedingt hier ja ich hab da alles
daran dass wir in die mitte jaja das
grün dass die grün zu grün aber so
seitliches ist ziemlich eklig die
künstlichen unterhaun
egal jetzt wird nicht gespielt
kannst du gucken arriva nicht schießen
wenn die wenn ich mich so bauer
sollte nämlich eigentlich noch ab
chillig leichtes drohne soll
hier hatten wir noch eine am leben alter
ja ich weiss nur 2 aber wenn wir so über
wochen kann nämlich eigentlich nicht
runter schießen oder nicht okay okay ich
habe einen gaben getrockneten eines weg
oder wow wow wo ich kritischer treffer
also der da oben vielleicht den wir mit
dem bogen getroffen haben aber zumindest
mal keine gold apples also müssen damit
rechnen dass die volle leben habt ihr
noch mal getroffen wie drüben
ja ok donnerstag attacke einer reineren
hatte die grün ist das grün ist es ja
kommen
die box mit der hand biss sind schöppl
den anderen sehr schön und 321 runde
alter okay was sagen wir mal zum schluss
lassen